[inaudible]
like a boss.
Let's get back to what went down this fucking week.
Damn God.
Damn.
Mother fuckers,
Alabama Crimson tide one yet another fucking championship.
Oh God dammit.
Georgia had a bad,
I'm on the fucking ropes and then the second half came along.
And what happened?
Georgia goes right out there and blocks a punt.
[inaudible]
I don't know.
Can somebody tell me how that guy was offsite?
Can somebody tell me why a bigger deal was not made other than on the mad dog
show?
They blew too brutal fucking calls when Alabama was making a great comeback.
Okay,
great coaching decision by Nick Saban to put that freshman kid in a quarterback
and to stick with them.
And how about the,
uh,
the start and not being a cunt about it?
That was all great.
And then they had that running back that came in and they started using in many
ways in the second half,
Alabama didn't,
he was just killing Georgia.
However,
I don't,
I don't use that fucking guy was not offsides.
They blocked the punt.
You looking at at least three points on that drive.
Granted people can missed field goals.
God knows Alabama knows about that come the end of the game.
Then they miss the face masks call and they call a ticky tack pass interference
on third nine.
Um,
those are the games.
When you're rooting for your team's getting fucked you,
you literally sit there going like,
this is literally,
it's just a t.
It's a TV show.
He can't have one team just beat the shit out of the other team.
Everybody's going to turn the channel
present real.
That football game was like watching an episode of the Super Friends back in the
day,
right?
Every fucking episode was the exact same with the super friends.
[inaudible]
justice
there are assembled the world's more greatest heroes created from the cosmic
legends of the universe.
Superman.
Okay.
Something would happen and then all of a sudden it just looked like,
you know,
whatever.
Superman had kryptonite around his neck,
a Batman and Robin would tied together.
And I'd like,
they think like they cared,
but you know,
tying that are heading towards a bud saw and all that type of shit.
And then something would happen.
That stupid fucking monkey from the wonder twins would do something
face monkey.
And the second they played that song,
wait
[inaudible]
and then I remember I would get a sense of relief every time I was watching that
cartoon.
I'm like,
Oh fuck,
is this the episode Superman dies?
I mean,
I was young,
I didn't know any better.
And the second they would start playing that song,
I knew that they will.
They were gonna make that comeback.
That's what the Alabama fucking band should've been playing when they,
when Alabama came running out in the fucking second half.
Oh,
maybe when they called off sides in that block,
pun.
Um,
you gotta give it up to Alabama,
even though I'm kind of being a cunt,
bringing those things up.
But Hey,
I mean,
that did happen.
That was bullshit.
The guy didn't even fucking move.
I Dunno.
Maybe.
Maybe the referee had a better angle.
I Dunno.
I don't want,
I don't get how you miss a face mask when it was done to the guy carrying the
football.
I mean the whole fucking stadiums looking at the guy,
his head turns around.
Ah,
say it.
We didn't see it.
Um,
here's what I want to know.
Who's more hateable bill Bellacheck or a Nick Saban.
And secondly,
why do you hate them?
Like everyone says,
Nick Saban is the devil.
Why is he the devil?
Because he's so good at what he does.
You know,
stupid thing.
I Dunno.
I think the media fucking hates bill Belicheck cause he makes that job so
fucking difficult because he knows that if he opens his mouth,
the media is going to make his job more difficult by exaggerating anything that
he said given the other team.
Bolton board material.
MMM.
Masterful.
The way he handles the press,
he gives them nothing.
He looks at them and he's like,
you people are not my fucking friends.
I am required by the NFL to stand here and answer your questions,
but I am not required to give you anything more than two fucking syllables per
question.
All right,
coach,
do you think the fans have a right to know about what happened to them with jam
or on Sunday?
I've already covered this.
[inaudible] to build something like that.
You can stick.
Okay,
but somebody's situation,
we don't try and find out if I've already covered it.
One specific to Chandler,
how much will,
what happened affect your usage?
You know the way you use them in the game against the chiefs.
What happened on Sunday?
Well,
we'll find out on Saturday.
I get to Xerox,
actually cover it again,
planning,
send it over to Kansas City if you'd go,
I mean it might be easier for all of us.
All right.
I love it.
I wish more coaches would do that.
More players would do that.
You know,
Shaq used to do it.
You ever Seen Shaq?
Like when I,
when he,
what he's doing like on TBS or whatever,
t and t,
whoever does the fucking NBA,
just total sky,
affable brick area stair.
I right.
Nobody would do like a,
he's talking joking around animated and all that,
but what he used to do those,
those interviews at the end of the game he just be like,
cool beer,
get rid of the ball.
Prejudicial.
He just went into like worker era or whatever you see on any other show.
It seems like a completely different guy.
That's what you learn after you get burned by those fucking nonathletic fat fuck
cops that are in the sports media.
I know you were frustrated at how the fishing officiating went down the stretch
there,
but you guys pulled it out.
It was a big
[inaudible] shack where I live.
I know.
Or maybe I just love when Alabama loses,
like my favorite part of that game was fucking Nick Saban's face at halftime.
He had to do that fucking
what did he had to do that interview,
that stupid fucking interview.
Why they stopped those poor bastards,
the most important game of their goddamn career and they got to sit there and
talk to fucking Susie sweet shoes as they before they go with it.
There are banks are running hard quarterbacks.
Make some really good decisions allowed you to get out to a 13 of a lead going
into the locker room.
I also think Georgia's front forward and credible like that interception that
kid had.
I mean usually defensive Lineman,
uh,
I dunno,
they're just not quick enough.
Ricocheted off the how many found it in the air and then caught it,
um,
in that close to the quarterback.
That usually does not happen.
And uh,
yeah,
they amazing front for and George's quarterback to the freshmen obviously kind
of sucks that they ended up losing the game.
I feel.
I actually will tell you this,
I felt bad for Nick Saban when that kid missed that field goal.
[inaudible]
it's funny,
for some reason I didn't feel bad for the kid.
I felt bad for nick say,
but
I forget what he did.
He just threw his fucking arms up.
Like,
what do I have to do?
How big a genius do I have to fucking be to fuck it.
Help you sons of bitches across the God damn gold line so he can win this thing
and go,
go home.
I want.
What more do I have to do?
Yeah.
I would love to interview coaches and be like,
what goes through your fucking brain?
All right.
Like an offensive coordinator,
whatever you call all the right place,
you play in fucking
high stakes chess,
where you literally,
your house,
your family standard of living is on the line because if you suck,
you're going to get fired.
And then w then way you're gonna go,
you're gonna have to fucking sell your house.
You Ain't know the deal pill.
We know that deal.
And you call all the right play.
60 minutes of playing chess on television where every fucking Douche in the
world like myself is going to second guess you who has never even coached the
game at a pop Warner level.
You get all the way down there.
It's a fucking chip shot.
Yeah.
And this soccer style con goes in there and fucking Mrs said like,
just what?
Like how do you sleep that night?
I,
I can't,
I can't imagine.
You know what I mean?
Everybody talks about the field goal kickers when they miss it and what they
have to deal with.
You know,
it's,
it's very simple.
Okay.
Nobody knows what a field goal kicker looks like.
You move out of this state,
you start selling cars,
you begin a new life,
egg,
noodles and ketchup somewhere,
right?
Yeah.
I can't imagine the coach.
So you got it.
How do you go to sleep at night?
You know,
and you know,
your wife doesn't understand.
College is just a game.
Come back to bed.
I don't understand what is wrong with you.
You're scaring the children,
Michael.
Okay
guys.
Just I would,
you know what I would do?
I would just be standing up in my living room drinking with my headset still on
staring at the fucking wall.
Okay.
Kids,
we're going to go to bed early tonight.
Your father's had a tough day.
I Dunno.
That's what I see when I,
when Nick Saban's losing,
when I look at that guy's fucking face,
it's just like,
I would not,
it's just not a guy you'd want.
You would want to piss off.
Um,
I love those guys that are going bald and they still dye their hair and they
still keep it like long.
I don't know.
What is Nick Saban Doin?
Please got cotton candy on top of his head.
Um,
anyways,
let's plow ahead.
By the way,
Nhl fans,
did you happen to catch?
Did you happen to see the fucking best game of the year?
They look great on the Justice League.
There are assembled the world's greatest heroes from the cosmic legends of the
universe.
Superman.